schlimme ausschreitungen in philadelphia
demonstranten bringen die polizei zurück
gegenstände fliegen auf die beamten
es folgen gewalttätige
auseinandersetzungen dabei werden rund
30 polizisten verletzt eine polizistin
erleidet einen beinbruch als sie von
einem pkw angefahren wird
neben den schweren unruhen auf der
straße kommt es auch zur plünderung
weniger als zwei stunden autofahrt von
new york entfernt
der grund polizisten haben einen 27
jährigen schwarzen erschossen
der mann soll mit einem messer bewaffnet
gewesen sein und die beamten bedroht
haben
mehrfach soll die polizei den
verdächtigen aufgefordert haben die
waffe fallen zu lassen
doch der bewegt sich weiter auf die
polizei zu es folgen mehrere schüsse auf
den schwarzen
rotter wallace stirbt laut seiner
familie soll er unter psychischen
problemen gelitten haben
es folgen heftige ausschreitungen in
philadelphia bereits seit ende mai kam
es immer wieder zu protesten gegen
rassismus und polizeigewalt nachdem der
schwarze george floyd bei einem
polizeieinsatz getötet wurde
wieder ist ein schwarzer amerikaner von
polizisten erschossen worden wallace war
mit einem messer auf polizisten
losgegangen
die polizisten hatten ihn mehrfach hier
sehen wir auch das video auf gefällt
dieses messer fallen zu lassen dann
feuerten die polizisten los der mann
starb kurz darauf an den
schussverletzungen in philadelphia
er ist jetzt unser reporter maximilian
kiene wir haben gerade schon gesehen und
wollen einmal nachfragen wie dort die
aktuelle stand ist denn es kommt immer
wieder zu unruhen dort ja sie na du hast
es gesagt und natürlich sind das bilder
und eindrücke die so kurz vor der us
wahl eigentlich niemand haben wollte
erst diese tödlichen schüsse auf den
jungen afroamerikaner das video ist ja
nur schwer zu ertragen und dann die
bilder danach proteste und auch
plünderungen plünderungen die live hier
im fernsehen national weit ausgestrahlt
wurden
das alles sind momente so kurz vor der
us-weit die niemand haben wollte und
über die jetzt natürlich die ganzen usa
diskutieren
wir stehen jetzt hier mitten in
philadelphia im westen der stadt da wo
eigentlich dass das epizentrum dieser
proteste stattgefunden hat in den
letzten 48 stunden vor der polizeiwache
im achtzehnter distrikt die im höhepunkt
der proteste tatsächlich auch die
menschen versucht haben zu stürmen und
anzugreifen
die polizisten hatten ja helme und
schilder auf um ihre polizeiwache zu
verteidigen das sind die eindrücke hier
aus der stadt und max was wissen wir zum
derzeitigen stand über das opfer von
diesen tödlichen polizeischüssen ja ich
würde sagen es gibt zwei perspektiven
das eine ist ein afroamerikaner der auf
die straße gerannt kommt der ein messer
in der hand hat der damit rum fruchte
zwei polizeibeamte die mehrmals rufen
stop stop bleiben sie stehen bleiben sie
stehen der sich den beamten nähert und
weiter mit dem messer herumfuchtelt die
andere perspektive ist die dass der mann
psychisch krank war dass das die polizei
wohl auch wusste die polizei war an dem
tag mehrfach schon in der wohnung
die mutter des getöteten hat auch kurz
vor den tödlichen schüssen den beamten
gesagt mein sohn leidet am bipolaren
störungen also das sicherlich etwas was
die polizei hätte einpreisen beachten
können bei dem weiteren verhalten was
dann passiert ist und macht in wenigen
tagen ist es soweit dann wird der neue
präsident gewählt welche auswirkungen
könnte jetzt die situation in
philadelphia auf die us wahl haben
ja ich habe es ja vorhin schon gesagt
diese bilder sind national weit gelaufen
und man muss sich das so vorstellen
bei einigen nachrichtensendern sieht man
dann im linken bild den us präsidenten
der gerade eine rede hält und im rechten
bild sieht man live szenen wie geschäfte
in philadelphia geplündert werden
natürlich entfalten diese bilder eine
gewisse macht und natürlich sind das
bilder die der präsident
instrumentalisieren nutzen kann sagen
kann ich bin der mann der für ordnung
sorgt schaut euch an was philadelphia
ist eine demokratisch geführte stadt in
diesen städten passiert das hat er auch
schon getan hat gesagt schaut was aus
meiner stadt schon bisher zur schule
gegangen passiert ist kauft schaut was
sie damit gemacht haben und das ist
sicherlich die rhetorik die wir auch in
den letzten tagen noch erwarten können
und dürfen und was glaubst du jetzt
konkret werden die proteste weitergehen
oder werden sie abheben
ja es gibt zwei veranstaltungen zwei
dinge die aufhorchen lassen einmal wird
heute im laufe des tages ivanka trump
die tochter des präsidenten in der stadt
fargo erwartet für eine
wahlkampfveranstaltung und dann rückt
hier ab morgen die nationalgarde 1
also männer und frauen in uniform in
militäruniform mit sturmgewehren die
dann ab freitag die lage in der stadt
kontrollieren sollen bis zur wahl
es wird abzuwarten sein was das mit der
stadt macht die vergangenheit in den
letzten monaten hat eigentlich gezeigt
dass dieser macht aufmarsch erstmal er
dazu führt dass es die leute wieder auf
die straßen treibt die ihre straße
sozusagen ihre stadt zurück haben wollen
und dann wird am dienstag gewählt und
dann schauen wir wie es hier in den usa
weitergeht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren